now and then you just came you just
can't use came from Disneyland yes are
we on yeah okay are we yeah okay yeah
all right nice segue Brad
hey are we on like I would have answered
you differently sure you know what I
mean it's not that was a pre podcast
yeah no I just was at Disneyland with my
friend Mike Carlson yeah who was in my
movie handsome he's a funny writer that
streaming on Netflix starring Adam ray -
ray I mean but I also brought with me
tonight and he's a little bit of shy
yeah mr. Jimmy Buffett which is first
this is unbelievable this is crazy
because look we're all Jimmy Buffett
fans everyone I think if you have a
heart and you're alive and you walk you
get up in the morning out of a bed or a
box or something yes you've heard of
Buffett you like Buffett take a step
back you're getting up out of a box by
the way I think you're getting up out of
a box you maybe didn't hear of Jimmy
Buffett you know nothing of anything and
you can't function as a human I mean a
box you turn with a homeless person
some people have real bad sciatica and
they like they don't stay in a box or
sleep on the floor but they need a box
were they a puppy they box by box might
be on the floor well such bad shape
well he wants to keep quiet but okay why
me because it's it's not too often that
we get to have not one but two
celebrities here on the podcast so the
fact that while you're considering me
and select oh no I think I'm a man of
somewhat comedic success yeah
but I would never I would never refer to
myself as a celebrity celebrity I think
is obviously like you know Glenn Close
but you know celebrity is someone who
it's about Fame you know okay that's
never about so for you it's about the
work in the craft oh stop with the work
by the way it's all good I don't think
my look I don't take myself seriously
but I take myself seriously enough as a
human being not to refer to myself as a
celebrity now
can i Jimmy Buffett do you do you
consider yourself a celebrity I mean I
really can't argue with that logic that
is if I was straight on deserted island
that would probably be more three people
I mean what do you go to many
two-bedroom apartments in Hollywood
these days or is this kind of a big deal
for you you're angering Jimmy Buffett
Adam well I doubt I'm gonna have candles
I even this was not a intentional but
its Aloha coconut chapstick and let's be
honest if there was a Buffett you know
lip balm do you have any deals with
chapstick your deals with everyone you
know I mean you got something to work
yeah now when you and Jimmy Buffett are
just walking around Disneyland what like
I don't know what you got like what what
ride do you hit first
what's the performing we're not doing in
California California Adventure but the
one where you float above the world
yeah I love that one
Jimmy loves that did you like that one
do any of the characters freak you out
because I know some characters on that
ride but in Disneyland in general oh
when you're walking amongst the park
yeah the Queen kind of weirded me out
today from uh from snow white she act
around
oh well she's e by the way Jimmy
something bothered you who did you see
together that you were unnerved by what
do characters were walking together
basically
yeah that cottage he was very upset I
didn't care for the new friendship what
do you got what do you got against TGI
Fridays I mean he owns Margaritaville
right Wow
I mean but I could what what do you
think is the longest actual time you
could ride around with Jimmy Buffett cuz
it's you know you know a lot of people
like to hang with and just wait keep it
chill yeah
now do you do the fold now you say
you're not a celebrity but you do the
full celebrity thing you go to
Disneyland you get the tour
do you yeah of course I get the guy yeah
okay look I'm on I'm in a lot of Pixar
movies yeah to do that about to do no
one yeah for Toy Story for at some point
on record but I'm also on the Goldbergs
which is ABC which is owned by des come
on so I call up ABC I say I'm going on
Monday may I have a guide please and
they give me a guide today as name was
Jack and he knew everything about
Disneyland it was great spero I loved
that have been real cool very did not
bit of real cool good upset you would
have liked to get be like mr. Gaurav
infinite the gold boots would you like
to ride the Mad Hatter just drop it the
fourth wall your name is Jeff so anyhow
did you working non-stop
yeah it's a little much you know I'm
about to start another season of Curb
Your Enthusiasm when's that starting
weight was there filming April 25th is
that least public knowledge yeah okay so
that's out yeah okay that's fantastic
yeah thank I'm excited cuz the last
season was like just watching it you
always think when when you have such an
iconic show like that and it comes back
from their season you're like oh can it
top itself and I really think you guys
did it was fan
pastic I love what were to do this
season so I might know how pumps I mean
David Sandberg was telling us when it
was just getting I think he just
received all the stories and he was like
he was like I don't know how they babe
Larry has strung together already's to
make it all flow and and so to hear you
say that it's pretty awesome no it's
fantastic what can't you what can you be
serious yeah and you can confirm or deny
Glen closes breaking news here we heard
it here first there is at least one big
movie star playing themselves in an
episode and so far my favorite episode
of the season really yeah Jimmy Buffett
who do you think it is he's a huge fan
so obviously he'd want to be in it yeah
what means what was your uh you can you
could post a little bit closer to you
know it's got to pick up it makes it
real well my voice come on yeah I don't
need help uh what was your favorite part
about returning to Disneyland or the
curb to curb yeah sure cuz it have been
what sev oh no just working with my
friends here's the thing about Curb Your
Enthusiasm I don't have to learn the
lines and I laugh all day that's all we
do we take their jobs very serious you
dope hard but we have fun we just laugh
all day long it's so much fun
yeah it just it's usually guys just
getting paid to hang out with your
friends well kinda
well as long as one of them's a genius
and he writes really cool stuff
hey then you can you know just hang out
all day but I got to come we should
bring that I think we should bring that
uber driver back I think you should have
his own harvest season I wasn't able to
be there because I filmed the Goldbergs
at the same time as curb last year so
when Adam did it and I was not there I
was there the one day that when I just
had to do the initial shot of me picking
Larry up that was on the same day of you
guys shooting inside so I came early
just to watch you guys on set right
because I want to see the magic and it's
like you really do take it seriously as
much as you're laughing it's like after
he
take you guys were conferring and we
discussing jokes maybe like well maybe
that again was fun what's going on that
path but not I'm saying like say that
exact thing again it was keeping it so
open to have it be different every time
I try unless I'm told by the director or
Larry that we didn't get something in
coverage I try every take to do
something different yeah just to just
give him different options yeah yeah
also to make them how much you trying to
make Larry laughs never no no and I
don't break you know I broke one I've
broken one
Larry breaks a lot but I only broke once
in the history of the show and that was
the episode it was called officer Krupke
and in the episode where's the women's
Underpants yeah because I my wife
discovers a lady's Underpants I'm like
yeah you're Larry David you happen to
enjoy wearing women's underwear
so Larry when he drops his pants for the
police officer I wasn't even though I
knew it was coming
are you ever prepared for Larry and also
making the face and then deliver saying
that so convincingly I'm also more
terrified of you if you don't break in
in that scenario I was so you know so
but generally you know really funny
things happen I stay focused I'm good
will you you guys are all shooting we
can't say anything about it what I was
gonna ask in LA again yes that's the
best right yeah that's great and then
there love sleeping in my own bed
I love napping in my own bed more than
sleeping in my own bed
you big Napper from way back he's an
old-school nap I did notice on the set
of handsome you had a chair that was yes
that was a zero-gravity chair
yeah but yes I liked the napping but I
speaking of uber yeah I you know it's so
funny I said - I was at maybe you were
coming by that night I I'm being serious
that but I remember some I remember you
gonna perform that night no I was just
hanging around I was going like oh I was
gonna I was going down
but the comedy started I was going down
being picked up by a friend of mine and
she said I'm gonna get cut noob or
whatever and I think it's gonna be an
uber black cuz that's whether I'll even
do a Lux on occasion I'm rich
[Laughter]
Jimmy Buffett what do you do for an uber
Margaritaville uber by the way if that
was an option after uber Lux uber
Buffett or over Margaritaville yeah but
anyhow I went into an uber X and then
and I was like and I just was telling
Adam you know from the Commodore that I
will never go in an uber X and then one
picks me up I'm like alright what the
hell I'm just going down to the Roxy to
see the English Beat okay and literally
the driver
she made a mistake I saw her making the
mistake and we got rear-ended and I
yelled no to stop her before she did her
thing and I didn't know we get
rear-ended so my back when I filmed
handsome the entire time I was in credit
and incredible back pain so I had a
chair and a massage table with ice packs
and in between setups when they were
setting up the cameras and stuff I'd be
laying on my back oh wow with the ice so
so that wasn't just you being diva Jeff
Garlin that was like although when I'm a
curb and the Goldbergs I have a zero
gravity chair and in between setups I do
nap my back's better but then it was all
about putting the ice in there and it
helped helped immensely but the move one
of things I'm really proud of handsome
is when you see me getting in and out of
cars it's really painful but you see
like a guy getting slowly in and out of
a car you never see that in a movie yeah
it's always very brisk yeah how quickly
can you shut down when you get in
position for an app like are you an
immediate passer router or do you have
to like sort of dream in of fun stuff I
would say you dream of borrowed cruises
for for an app no more than a five
minute delay Jesus Wow and I've gone
down within 30 seconds absolute brow I
want
yeah and I can also have a cup of coffee
and take a nap right away part of the
next Marvel movie by the way one of the
things I'll tell you if you can do that
do it because when you wake up when you
wake up from it you don't feel groggy Oh
interesting because so the caffeine
kicks in like while you're sleeping
while your sleep but it's delightful now
he Adam briefly touched upon that that
would be a good platform for a Marvel
movie you are a big comic book fan but
not a Marvel or DC movie fencer once
like I love Deadpool ok I loved the you
know individual ones leave you tell me
one I'll tell you I dug it didn't take
it ant-man never even saw it
I had no desire yeah well ok well cuz he
he he knows me so it's like he doesn't
have to see a move at a man who's making
very small now well and I asked because
of course the big phenomenon in the last
few months has been black panther did
you see that one I did I I thought it
was good very good even I didn't think
it was like great mm-hmm I was just like
what
can't handle overhype I was hyped to the
help but you gotta admit a movie with
mostly black people being a gigantic
money maker yeah yeah that's fantastic
yes wonderful but it was ok it was good
you know now you say you're not DC or
marvel so is there a semi complex from
both okay I don't buy i buy mostly back
issues now I don't really like I'm
trying to think if there's a current
book that I love like certain runs
people will do a run on spider-man or a
run on Batman or whatever I'll go oh
I'll talk to the people at my complic
store earth-2 in Sherman Oaks nice and
yeah to earth the good folks at earth
too
I got other accomplices other nice ones
nice people but that's my main one
are they quintessential stereotypical
comic book guys that work there no it's
mostly women that work there Wow yeah
the guy cuz there's a guy who owns his
name's car
but though there's women who work there
and they're very helpful I go what run
is really good now because I love story
yeah art is secondary to me like you
know I used to like old artists like I
love Neal Adams I love John Buscema like
I'm really into cow books it's amazing I
hate comp movies for the most part
interesting why because the stories are
just no I don't care for example
Deadpool I cared about the character
yeah me too passionately yeah what
happened to him what happened to his
wife
I cared yeah these movies I don't care
most of the cos it's just so like
Panther everyone could have died and he
essentially dead you're one of the but
but I'm saying Buffett did you see Black
Panther yes starring starring the man
that yeah that my wife Rose have has
told me that she would cheat on me with
like in front of me if it was her and
Jason Momoa she would not care she was
like would you clap and rhythm as they
[ __ ] pretty much let's keep the timing
going I mean Wally you know he's got his
own rhythm women do dig that dude I will
say although I didn't even see the JIT
like I didn't go see the Justice League
movie nah me neither
cuz it looked like crap yeah yeah
Wolverine movies um Hugh Jackman's got
his edge to him by the way he's really
good they're good yeah like I don't hate
those but I I've hated others Iron Man I
like that I like the first one yeah
they're all fine but it would it would I
hate what about Captain America good
yeah great you know easy chef guy have
you seen the trailer for that chef Guy
it's about Chef Boyardee and he learns
how to by the way you realize that's not
why you laughing Brad it's funny to me
don't joke about boy Artie superiority
reference by the way that was just not
funny
without him I expect more if it wasn't
trying to be oh I use Padres movies I
love it
Adam is the best guy and funny and good
Nigel I'd fall and the handsome well
thanks for look at you well thanks for
Brad the ladies must just finger
themselves I mean that's why we had to
stop doing live shows together yeah yeah
are you it was just a problem yeah
speaking doing live shows we just did a
big one together
oh yeah the k-rock thing yeah we did the
Kevin bean april fools yeah yeah that
was uh there was six thousand people
yeah
was that the largest audience you've
ever done stand-up no I've done first
10,000 and I hated it Wow and so where
was ten thousand and in San Jose maybe
it was in San Francisco and the point
being is that I didn't like it and I
really liked that theater that was fun
yeah the other Microsoft year and down
in downtown Los Angeles there before no
I'd been on stage I've been I was there
for Emmys numerous times
oh cool yeah but you know really yeah
the ward shows in general hate them
passionately hate them why is that have
you been to one nope all right my friend
let me just tell you ahead of time it's
an honor to be nominated sure it's great
to win and what a Golden Globe yeah
Golden Globe is pretty fun that seems
well that's like work that's the one TV
people it's just it's just an that's a
more that's the most fun of all of them
but unless the host is like I've been
there when Shandling hosts I've been
there with Conan hosts you know it's
great when you have a funny host but you
know if you've a [ __ ] host so there's no
fun like bathroom stories like me Al
Pacino Glenn Close are all taking a [ __ ]
by the way that's true
Al Pacino Glenn Close they were taking a
[ __ ] in the same time different angles
it was a delightful time many good
stories which I promise I keep secret I
said I'm gonna tell everybody we shared
a toilet what is your question yeah you
live here yeah how do you deal with this
room do you take the pictures down and
the I'm not a fan of it I try to make
this my
now it's an office it's very much an
office podcast room yes like I feel like
I'm in a thing but if you live here
that's got to suck
yeah I mean look there's a walk-in here
and and you know I get obliviously I
mean look I I could probably take some
of the stuff down but that's a lot of
energy every day to put it up take it
down yeah yeah try to balance is that a
real poster for the movie is it one that
was made
the real poster oh it's cool pose made a
handful of them yeah and you know for me
I was like oh this this could be the
last time I'm in a poster well let me
just put it up your yeah don't do that
positive thoughts all right I don't go
for that now combo yeah but be confident
yeah that you know what you're doing is
a comedic actor feel like I do and you
you you'll work it's all about
confidence you having confidence but be
humble be like I'm lucky if I'm in the
heat yeah I mean well I want to ask you
this what was it like and you can be
very candid for because auditioning for
curb I went in twice I think you were
there the first time maybe the second
time yeah because of the schedules yeah
and this season I'm there every day for
everything for curb did you enjoy that
yeah yeah yeah I mean so so I went in
first time for the uber driver and look
I was it was one of the things were you
know like we talked about favorite show
of all time very pumped even be there
and the nerves were running high on the
way there and then when I got there
everything just settled down it was just
like you said it was a very like
humbling confident of like confidence
were were you know what you're doing
yeah I was like hey you know right wait
you got to this moment for a reason
that's exactly right but also what is
there if you're auditioning why should
you be nervous nervous for what nothing
bad can happen to you yeah either you
get the part or you don't yeah so you
might as well when you're auditioning
for anything do it with joy yeah because
there's you either get the party you
don't so what are you nervous about that
you'll fail and guess what you probably
will fail yeah you probably won't get it
you know and not because you're good or
bad just because you're not exactly
right
it's like there's a the odds are stacked
against you so how
a great time I did try to let a little
that seep in of like all right well you
might not get it you know but I wanted
it but how do you how do you meet that
with like wanting it so bad which is
what I was letting myself get overtaken
with well by the way you want it but you
know it's just look here's what it is
man you got a job to do yeah and you got
to take what you do seriously and don't
take yourself seriously yeah and if
you're wanting it too bad you're taking
yourself seriously no is this something
that you've learned through a read
somewhere that you started doing
Transcendental Meditation transmittal
meditation for years but no that's not
okay yes everything in my life
experience has led to me knowing these
things you know but it's it's it really
don't let the ego overcome you yeah
don't just be like this is what I do man
and I'm going to do it yeah yeah and and
and you know and you'll do the see that
great what what I always wanted to do
and what I aspire to do is do what I do
and then if I leave an audition or I
film something and I've done what I
wanted to do yeah I've done my part yeah
and that's what I try to preach and did
that on my movie yeah you did what you
wanted to do and that was exactly what I
wanted you to do cool and that's why I
hired you you know as I recall did you
audition for my movie no you just gave
it to me
all right that's correct yeah cuz I knew
you could do Sami and something and said
I'm gonna put you in this no that's not
what happened I thought what you said no
no I show up to your door with a boom
box over my head you know but the point
thing is I knew you I knew what you were
capable all right I'd seen your work I
seen you do stand-up and I'm like you
can nail this you know yeah and
hopefully I'll do another one and you'll
do that character yeah I loved it but in
curb so so when I walked in it was like
III remember I made a just thing Allison
and you were very familiar faces so that
couple me and Allison Jones Allison
Jones your show introduced people yeah
virgin knocked up the top casting
marketer
of all time in comedy something and and
so seeing you guys helped and then
seeing Larry was like that was the first
time so it was like a definitely a
starstruck moment but then like it all
went away very quickly and then once we
sat down it was like well he gets the
business yeah and I made a joke and he
laughed kinda and about knowing Carol
Leifer and having mutual friends and I
said you guys you guys used to date or
something but through JDate or something
and he laughing and something like that
something to acknowledge like all right
yeah and then we sat down and jumped
into it and it was you just got act
I remember everything kind of going
blank and from yeah you got a job to you
that's the way you approach remember him
well you guys have a job yeah okay so
you did the right thing yeah you had
confidence in your abilities and you're
focused on that you weren't focusing on
while you're doing the scene you're not
thinking to yourself oh I want this so
bad now that's Larry David behind me
which people do and they do they end up
saying that out loud they don't get the
job if they do that but I can see yeah
and it's like they're so excited you
know and it's like that's all good and
fine but you've got to be a when you go
up to bat in a baseball game in the
crowds the crowds here they're cheering
for me know it's like what's that
picture thrown I've already scouted him
then look how lucky I am this is the
humble part I play professional baseball
I'm about to go to bed how great is that
but I know how to do it and I'm here for
a reason and that's where you have to
approach everything he's got a listening
to real lucky that you'll get the
opportunity and you just do what you do
what's your skill set man and just do it
how long before it took you to to
realize these things get caught I
started I started stand-up and acting
when I was 20 mm-hmm and I started
getting reasonably good at both and
figuring it out about ten years later
yeah ten years I'd say what you guys say
ten years is like to be able to start
and then you know and then every year
from that more and more and more and
more confidence confidence confidence
confidence and humbleness with the
confidence that combination you can't
lose when you're in an audition room on
the other end for this curb casting dear
how much will you chime in if you see
something like let's say somebody
doesn't come in as poised and confident
as I did I want a pool but if you say no
when they walk in I make a point of
going up and shaking their hand and I
tell them have the most fun ever I hope
you really enjoy this like I set it down
for them yeah and then generally if they
miss the mark by that much we just let
him leave because Larry the Larry's not
every rooms like if I'm a director and I
see something in someone I will in fact
give them a note to change something
yeah but on curb Larry wants somebody
who really punches him in the face that
they're the parked that they're it he
doesn't like you putting a spin or
trying to be clever somebody recently
was very good but they were a little too
clever
he said they sort of seemed like they
were in a madtv's get skit
it's a skit skit and he was right and
then he get the part and I knew they
could have made the adjustment but
sometimes it comes down to something so
small like that yeah well it's nuanced
you know but and on our show he'd he's
not a big make adjustment guy he's like
you do it like if he's gonna make an
adjustment with somebody he's gonna make
it within the first 10 seconds where
they're completely going down the wrong
path he doesn't want to waste his time I
understand we also don't rehearse so the
rehearsal yet he's seen is during an
audition yeah so they can't do it and he
can't vibe and they don't get it then
yeah why try to take them on when yes
it's such the kind of a show where you
know the kind of quality of people that
are gonna be going out for these parts
like it's it's like pro sports where
it's like if someone can't do it alright
next man up or its man up next woman up
like it's warming up boom good night
everybody but that's show business man
mm-hmm
you know just have the attitude work
hard to gain the confidence and then
when you got the confidence you got a
job to do and
you know how to do it and always you're
lucky to be doing the job how lucky am i
you know I'm a to hit shows [ __ ] I'm
create by the way exhausted didn't like
doing him at the same time took away a
lot of the joy yeah but I always knew I
was lucky and I wasn't gonna complain
how do you find that of the shows two
completely different mindsets like I
don't even thing for a clown I don't
think about that either I just go I mean
like having having a script versus not
having a script is I don't even have my
process for each yeah and I just do it
what do you actively trying to fit
stand-up in between there or sometimes
are you just busy where you're not way I
actually get on stage because how I met
The Improv every Friday that's right yes
in the lab with doing a show with the
greatest name of a show ever which is
you'll probably get laid yeah well they
said what do you want to call it and
that's the first thing I thought it
about what a great title yeah because if
you're looking down this realize the
irony of it's called you'll probably get
laid with Jeff Garlin I didn't intend
for that I intended it to be your
probably get laid period yeah ya know
with Jeff Kerry or whatever I didn't
think about that just turn it off and
I'm gonna be starting up again at
flappers on Sunday nights every Sunday
at 7:00 awesome starting in August
that's a great time that's a great show
and that's a jinx
so I'll be doing an hour on Fridays at
The Improv and an hour on Sundays at
flappers and then once a month I'm at
Largo what does this go up next week
okay yeah so this Friday I'm up at Largo
and John mulaney's my guest with them
he's with I'm talking to Larry Charles
interviewing Larry Travis I felt yes I
bump curb Borat again these different
things wait is this when I went to the
one where you interviewed Larry is this
the same time the podcasts are you doing
for a little bit well no I stopped doing
Stokes like a similar form okay good I
don't do because you're so good at that
though I mean thank you
I don't do a podcast anymore because I
don't
the time and I'm filming you know I'm
doing my stand-up you know you guys know
commitment it's a commitment and you got
a record commercials you got to do all
this stuff you got a horse like yes tree
between your partner and laughs
hopefully candles and a surprise guest
does it but do you have any best friends
that you sometimes feel like I don't
want to do this but there's there's
there's you know there's something to be
gained from it so I'm gonna force myself
to do it
[Laughter]
what sort of fur made May Birds former
mayor made favorites and what is that
that is not something on the menu at
Margaritaville what sort of ride for my
favorites fried what sort of mermaid
favors are getting what what was more
fun today
Jeff Garlin riding the ride of
Disneyland or talking with Jimmy Buffett
at all times talking with Jimmy Buffett
there was the time where I did enjoyed
talking with you about the nights you
know by the way today haunt the Haunted
Mansion today was fantastic something
different about it just know you know
what it is is every time I go to
Disneyland probably once a year mmm and
I love Disneyland but every time it's a
different experience who you're with who
you with on the ride today I was on the
ride my friend Mike Carlson and Jimmy
Buffett were in the yeah and I was by
myself okay and so it just was I just
really enjoyed it yeah just enjoyed it
and I got to the whole beginning the
elevator with the whole thing yeah I got
to experience that with just Jimmy
Buffett and Mike Carlson today oh wow
and Jack yeah yeah the tour guide are
you okay with really big drops and crazy
just the rides that they can make you
know oh no no I don't go on them yeah
they went on them all day and I sit on
the bench and close my eyes and take a
quick
sometimes it's a three minute nap
sometimes it's a ten minute back to that
yeah now they really have you always
been so no coasters no crazy you're
slowing hate roller coast now because of
the fear of falling off or that your
stomach can't handle it fear of falling
on every year there's a new story
published where it's like somebody off
the Matterhorn and I'm like Jesus Christ
I don't even get that far yeah like this
neighborhood possibility for me don't
even look at the Matterhorn in the ice
by the way I remember working at a
record store this is in Florida and one
of my co-workers said to me how to dream
about you last night she goes I go
always a button she goes you fell off a
roller coaster now prior to that another
one on roller coasters yeah someone does
a dream like that you're definitely not
going on now yeah
this is I don't want Space Mountain I
don't go on the Matterhorn I don't go on
the you know by the way even the dry
love parts the Caribbean even at first
parts that Caribbean drop yes
that one gets to me but I still I go
through with that one else too much no
its bordering on too much okay but
rollercoasters no way like I would not
like you know I've never been is what's
the place up the five there's no six
bikes alright Six Flags
I've never been to Six Flags this is
there's nothing that place could offer
me this is so funny to many will never
go why what are you offering nothing
nothing I'm supposed to sit at my car in
the parking lot more than going I'll
even walk yeah I'm laughing so hard at
this because the other three people
sitting at this table right now two of
them hate roller coasters the person
that loves roller coasters is a
[ __ ] who can't get on half of
the damn roller coasters ya know it's
his attitude I don't like women gives me
to thing is they won't let him on rides
anymore no so really that's right the
height yeah I can reason which if you
have the chance for a dwarf to fly
across the sky you're that's a great
marketing I think you do that I think
your role that does yeah
exactly much as you're making a joke I
don't want to see at least no one have
sound mine unless they're sleeping in
boxes want to see a little person the
appropriate little person yes wait wait
little no one wants to see a little
person fly or fly out of a rollercoaster
out of a roll because if Brad one knows
I'll see you later and goes flapping his
wings and I go way back
ruin the effect rocket pack no I'd like
to seem just fly like a superhero I want
to see my wings I already look weird
enough Adam now you can put wings on me
a big ass in a Peyton Manning forehead
have you ever been so high that you felt
you were flying or you thought you saw
something flying what was the name of
the Pelican you know what I love you
Jeff Garlin but I may love the fact that
you have Jimmy Buffett here why would
you wait are you really set on conan
have pot has become a new part of your
life it's an important part of my life
because I have trouble sleeping me till
because of anxiety and disappointment
until Rhett and indica God's gift to
people like me I know if I have a child
I'm naming it indica just to show my
appreciation for the drug it's it's
special how had you said you've been
against it or just never allowed it to
be never against it I always voted for
it even when I wasn't smoking and I was
like this is ridiculous
but I was doing the view and Whoopi
Goldberg I was telling her about my
problems on the air and afterward she
took me into her dressing room and gave
me a vape pen an indica vape pen and
when she goes well Goldberg tells you to
get high I think you have to listen at
that point Oh interesting certainly by
the way that it doesn't get cooler as an
intro into the world of
then we'll be go over being like hey
this you know that is her voice and she
didn't say it like that
she turn to a bebop jazz she said if you
explain to me she's so cool me numbers
of places in here great oh you know like
you know places to get it to get my
medical card like she set me on my way
and I owe her she's a big advocate for
yeah yeah I am too but I'm not gonna get
crazy about you know I got other things
to talk about
did you guys smoke together did you get
home will be no getting high with Whoopi
could be the new comedians in cars
getting coffee I feel like but if she
just pulls guests into the dress you
know no not first off you don't want to
get high near the view right but yeah
that's actually a good idea for her
getting high with Whoopi but she's
already keep the priority thought of it
maybe you do it in a hot-air balloon so
it's a play on words oh dear God
I don't know what I like more Adam when
he's funny or Adam disappointing Jeff
Garlin right now I don't see Brad going
off the rails well I mean I haven't had
an indicate the indica that makes you
more on the rail Brad can't smoke a ton
of pot because he's had some bad health
experiences yeah seriously though wait
is that true oh yeah edibles stay away
no how much is cooked into how much is
cooked into it it's like such a by the
way if you're gonna ever do edibles do
the smallest amount possible yeah and
the next time do a little bit break that
in half if it doesn't work yes
yeah I once tap-dance on my patio
because I for 15 minutes because in my
head I go if you don't stop tap dancing
your hearts gonna explode for about 15
minutes that's a crazy attaboy yeah and
if across the way my apartment complex
after about eight of the 15 minutes
somebody just goes are you okay so they
watch me step ball change for eight
minutes before they decide this guy's
not rehearsing for something well no I
mean I would wait a few minutes yeah but
it's yeah you don't it's too much of a
gamble yeah but you know you can control
the yeah I like smoking a joint and they
sell pre-rolled joints there you go
I like a babe when I travel you know you
have to get hot before you get on a
plane no no no why is that I don't need
to although I flew to my last edible
experience okay I knew I couldn't smoke
the vape on the plane and wasn't gonna
get high before where am i doing the
airport so I bought some edibles now I
don't eat sugar so I bought like some
Doritos style edibles okay okay and they
said they're indica well they turned out
to be sativa which is that puts you down
no that not all the things yeah but they
sort of for me cuz who doesn't do drugs
that's equivalent of acid man
and I had nightmares on the flight that
was just my head was spinning
flight mares really really thank you I
just I'm on hold
I just got back from why listen my brain
I'm not the time change stop breaking
stop quipping the most common focal my
brain
Jimmy did you think that was funny hey
how you doing
no I'm Brad you do kids you never called
me I at one of your favorite comedians
podcasts Patton Oswalt
no he's in the heat what an Sam man is
Michael McDonald yes she she says hi
yeah okay well I know what's going on I
haven't heard from him buddy yeah she's
looking for my son but you know she
loves Adam so much yep no no no no no
it's time for my son yeah yeah I've gone
in I used to go in to audition for stuff
for her since when I started ya know she
by the way I learned about you from
Marla for real oh my god she's the first
word told me about you before I ever met
you oh [ __ ]
oh she's like I love this guy I used to
I get running for so many things for
they got call back and call back for
more and more and then just would lose
out to my name you know that's the thing
with Brad Morris and I say the same
thing to you
okay and that is you get in this point
in your career where you work a ton and
you it's almost like your everyday
you're juggling but you keep being
handed balls but no-one's like here's
one big ball hold this and go sit like
this there's no you ever gotten the one
big thing yet yeah the one TV show the
one movie the one thing that's like yeah
daddy oh and it's gonna come I know that
cuz I juggled three years especially if
it's probably yeah a specific auld yeah
daddy Oh starring Adam right by the way
that would be great how many how many at
what point did you decide though like oh
maybe I'm just not gonna which I'm not
saying that this is how I'm thinking but
in the cuz I'm you know getting balls
and juggling them just didn't thing with
Paul Feig for his pilot and couldn't had
more fun doing just a day job on the
pilot right but walking away being like
I needed that day is like a reboost er
to be like yes of course it's that hard
in front of so many people and Paul and
be like oh yeah like this is not that I
was question when I was doing but
needing up a ball bigger I how do you
balance out being like oh maybe I'll
just get these little balls from oh no
no no it's not even that yeah you just
do what's keep doing it just keep doing
what you're doing and keep delivering
only worry about being great yeah not
good goods not good no it's not in show
business worry about being great just
everyday every job whatever you do if
you're gonna write that day just write
and do the best you can and that's all
you can do and then the rest of it it
just happens was there a moment your
career where you thought like where you
thought okay here we go
this is the break no the thing never as
a matter of fact I remember having a
conversation with John Stewart about
that like when did you you know there's
never that big what's your big break
when did like you don't even remember
like that and I actually remember
moments where I thought I'm never gonna
make it or election feeling down but I
didn't let that overcome me I hey here's
the thing perseverance in show business
is
not going nuts when no one is saying
your name when nothing is going on don't
go nuts just keep pushing forward keep
pushing forward they will say your name
I mean look at your co-star in the
Goldbergs Bryan Callen who's oh yeah one
just got picked up wait did he get
picked for the fall season
yeah they posted about today yeah shut
up yeah the the high school wasn't
enough to spit up yeah cuz it did great
in the time yeah yeah I guess it right
they voted good I'll see him in New York
at the upfront I'm so happy for him yeah
talk about a guy that's just he's been
he's mad at our years and it'll be a lot
of little balls in the air and now and I
was said did you get to a point you know
but I had moments like even in the
middle of having lots of balls where
there were no balls like where I didn't
work at all and my wife had to cast an
order for us to survive so you just keep
pushing for keeping for it that's such
great news so him in Tim Meadows look at
that oh yeah yeah that's awesome yeah
and how and how great does that it to
make something like Adam Goldberg feel
to now no he's he's launching like two
different shows passionate about it so
that's very exciting is is is a strange
plane someone who actually existed and
it is so obviously close to the creator
of the show leo
think about it you you you don't think
about like oh wait but the guy was dead
before I even started the show and I
didn't I'd seen video of him but I
didn't and then take that into
consideration you know you don't do that
you just do what you do yeah you don't
even think about I'm not a skilled
enough actor to to know it's true to
play this guy exactly the way he is no I
don't do that I just do what I do you
want somebody to do that you gotta have
a different type of actor well and
that's not who they hired they hired
Jeff Garlin yes so an embalmer
yeah it's the curmudgeon II sign of me
inside of me you know what about over a
hundred episodes you think about that
that's crazy yeah we're one hundred and
[ __ ] they were going into our sixth
season and curb this year crosses 100
episodes what yeah so I have two TV
series have gone past 100 that's I'm
you're in the tech dancing club know
what speaking of that Ted Danson's on
one of my hundred episode shows he's on
curb
yes he's has two seasons like a Reggie's
and by the way Pete gets me who's my
favorite person to ever work with and
without a doubt Ted Danson hey Jimmy
have you ever worked with that dancing
or come across them why not but if you
learned but what that's probably gonna
be at least a six-week what you have a
favorite episode of Curb do you watch TV
I should just start with that there's
there's so many celebrities that
wouldn't you see him together like I had
no idea that they would hang out and you
guys are definitely two of those
celebrities wait what is it about Ted
Danson dead cuz he's been I mean on he's
the most work shows was regular star
Lovejoy how does he work that long and
talented and he loves it still and he
loves it and you can feel it he's
everything you want me as a man I want
to be like him I want to be like him I
would be like Bryan Cranston to do the
show last year Kimmy
I mean to be around these people that
you want to emulate like that are I look
at and go man if I could be like that
and Ted dance is one of those people uh
this does he break yeah you know
but not really I mean he's he's oh he's
you know his skill levels pretty
gosh-darn i the episode with him and
Larry and the anonymous donor is my most
donors
it's maybe one of the greatest episodes
I mean look there's we could go down a
rabbit hole of this of Ted is okay was
saying he did it yes and Larry's
anonymous and he's furious yes and the
playfulness with him and Cheryl and and
you've been like which was touching and
like no it's right so and then Cheryl
ratting or Ted telling her that you're
the one that jerked off in the house yes
and then Susie banning Larry from and my
husband which is such a great thing
because she's always so anti it's like
for her she's always still got your back
yeah so finding out that Cheryl banned
Larry well then [ __ ] you you paid my
husband to get them yeah yeah I know
that's funny
I'm telling you lines that you said
alright I enjoy it's good I heard us I
heard a story about you and I have to
know if this is true yes I heard you an
interview say one time that you lost
your virginity to a heckler I lost my
virginity to a heckler on South Beach in
1982 yes
in a lifeguard stand Wow so I'm not
doing I was doing an house for me yeah I
was doing a show mm-hmm on South Beach
and back then South Beach was there were
two like bar nightclub places the
carlyle on the Cardoza and there was a
comedy club in the Victor hotel the the
top part was there were no you couldn't
go in the hotel rooms but the bottom was
a beautiful art deco comedy club you
know and I'm 20 years old that just
started in comedy and South Beach is
filled with Cuban refugees mm-hmm
artists and old Jews no that's the
mixture so which one of these did you
lose your virginity to all that well
actually no damn no that's what I told
you that was the scene I'm sad yeah yeah
so I'm on stage and there's a woman just
Hakala yelling at me that I stink and
this that new thing and by the way I did
stink up over 21 of year old Garland
talking I was an emcee I don't remember
yeah and afterwards I went down to the
Carlyle and
some guy comes up and he says my friend
wants to buy you a drink
and I go I don't really drink he goes
what can I buy you she buy you something
I go ginger ale he goes she's gonna come
over and bring it to you so the heckler
woman very attractive comes over brings
me a ginger ale I said I really don't
thank you but I'm just not interested in
you're not talking to you she's please
come out in front I want to apologize I
was terribly wrong we got in the front
and she grabs me kisses me literally
grabs me kisses me and I was like all
right that's a good apology and then she
starts running on the beach ripping off
her clothes
yelling follow me follow me I followed
her but I kept my clothes together I
didn't want to have to gather them she
ran up she's naked in a lifeguard stand
I go up in the lifeguard stand
I'm completely clothed I take off my
clothes and being the good Jewish boy I
bolted my clients Christ and I remember
thinking when my wiener went in it's
like oh it's over I'm not a virgin and
then please tell me you said that out
loud Jimmy but what's the first thing
you said when you lost your virginity
why did I think that's what you were
gonna say and where was it
yeah can you top lifeguard stand is a
location best that's the movie Joe
versus volcano should have been yeah my
god wait so yeah and then by the way it
to follow up there's more detail these
but no I don't wanna okay but but no at
the end she said you know you're really
sweet I'd love to see you again she gave
me her number
hmm and she said I'm an attorney here in
Miami no no she's got a job you know how
about that and then she told me she was
30 and I kept my composure but on the
way home I threw the number out the
windows like I'm not hooking up with a
30 year old Virginny and I'm not going
with an old lady thanks for the fun two
old thirty you kidding me yeah but when
you're 20 years old it seems
yeah she's look at her best life by the
way stripping off clothes running on the
beach at 30 and an attorney an attorney
has like a dream gal yeah young helping
a young crappy comedian lose his
virginity but that is I am a real
comedian I lost my now what was better
that are your Bar Mitzvah oh that yeah
because my bar mitzvah I remember it was
at Inverrary in Fort Lauderdale and I
remember all I remember is being
photographed like to smile like I look
at my bar mitzvah album and that's my
memory like the kids will be doing
things and I was taking a picture I was
taking a picture all I remember is
perfect pictures thank jimmied remember
your Bar Mitzvah
[Laughter]
how is being a dad at this stage in the
game I know your which is your son that
was on the set of handsome even Kirby
he's 22
yes he turned 22 last month and so a
younger son is 18 so my kids are 18 22
and I'm madly in love with them yeah
yeah adore you
I hope so it seems like it they let me
kiss him and hug him as much as I want
and I I respect them I think that's one
of the key things I don't let them do
whatever they want to do as I say we but
I have great respect for them and I try
and give them the respect but sometimes
it's difficult James it was on set for
handsome right yes yeah you were very
assertive about like being encouraging
but also very being a straight shooter
about if he was doing something wrong or
or taking or taking a moment to be like
this is something you should be thinking
about in in terms of what's in regards
to what's happening around yes remember
also I'm as dad well you could see that
relationship to a head like son right
yeah yeah like somebody telling him
something he's like what does this guy
know yeah I mean you know your dad you
know you know someday oh I know cuz I
certainly every boy goes through this
you look at your dad with respect but
right now come on man they don't they
lose the prime years to nominate Leah
yeah I know more than you dad yeah
especially in this type all my weight
James more than Duke the old one really
knows way more than me do they think
it's crazy you're not on Twitter no they
they respect that good
it is not being on Twitter you know it's
not if it's when I'm gonna say something
that I regret sure so I just like
Instagram where I don't regret pictures
yeah I do I just delete it yeah but but
I love it I got out a couple today from
Disneyland Jimmy Buffett is not in there
he asked me not to put him up Jimmy why
don't you like being photographed is
there Jimmy are you follow you Father
[Laughter]
what kind of advice do you give them a
fizz era a place you're looking to
travel to to do comedy anytime soon no
and just doing more stand-up like you
all know I did it in London over
Christmas with yeah really funny also
into a Chelsea game I went to Chelsea
game-winner yeah yeah now cuz I you're a
you're a historically famous Cubs fan
love the Cubs and and lifelong not just
in the last two years right it's long
you ever been on the podcast and se won
the World Series but no I have not yeah
before the world it might have been that
season actually when you were on might
have been I think that's I mean can you
at least just where were you when they
want for I was in well for because I was
there I was a I was at games three four
and five
what were the ones in Wrigley Field okay
even the Cubs in the World Series I'm
not going to Cleveland no really
I'll go to Cleveland $100,000 a day
mmm Jimmy Bob I've kind of like Jimmy
Buffett whatever Bobby
same with Vegas yeah my price if I'm
gonna go to Vegas that's $5,000 a show
you only gonna show you tell me it's
$100,000 and fly me on a private plane
my map actually I liked it driving yeah
driving that's the best part of Vegas is
the dry really okay that's the time on a
drive to Vegas
I'm just chill you know and what about
what about Vegas don't you like
everything everything yeah by the way
there's a Margaritaville on us you walk
into a casino that smell I know the
smell of desperation and poor people and
and smoke no because there's these are
people with their life savings putting
them into you're walking by at any given
moment somebody who you're watching
their life change your walk your and
you're soaking up that aura going down
on a tan yeah like I'm walking by people
winning the jackpot no yeah
and you know the thing I also know I
learned this a long time ago about any
casino any gambling situation have a top
and the bottom you know this is how much
I'll win if I win $500 or lose $500 I'm
out either way in between I'll keep
going great there is no bad or good yeah
and if you can end up with zero at the
end of the night what a successful trip
yeah you just had a lot of fun yeah
that's it
but when you think oh I can go more but
one more no I can lose them you're gonna
lose it just you got to have a top and a
bottom someone taught me that and so
clean clothes is there a sorry is zero
that one wasn't bad that's the last call
back of her is is there a game that you
do enjoy though that were you like at
all no I like napping well if we gamble
on napping you can gamble on napping I'm
a big bowl of bin wait so what did you
love about London doing stand-up there
that was so different from out here no I
just they were there for London they
were very enthusiastic not the most
enthusiastic audiences they're very
reserved but I sold out my shows before
even got to London so it was just fun to
just go do my shows they were happy to
see me I did my best I had some pretty
good ones you know he's you improvising
right I mean pretty everything that's
unfortunate for me I know I don't have
an act
so I mean I have stories that I'll
repeat you know and I don't know what
I'm gonna repeat each show but without a
doubt the lowest amount of improv that
that I'll do a show is 60%
generally it's I'd say it falls around
90% I'm making it up but people need to
understand that more when they see you
too because it's amazing but here's the
thing
they really don't here's why I shouldn't
get bonus points for that I should only
be really great but you are so then
there's then you give the bonus points
afterwards if you find out great but I
don't need the bonus point you're not
going in you never say during the show
this no I do I go you know I'm I have
but I do it more in a self-depreciating
right I say you know I'm not gonna get
funnier than I've already hit my I've
got nothing prepared for ya hey you
crushed that Kevin beans April
foolishness you do it with a hint of
jizz the whole pumpkin thing I made it
up on the ride there I want to open up a
a hypoallergenic pumpkin patch and then
I made up this whole story of me talking
to a guy who owns a pumpkin patch and he
says business is good and I said well
what if I got into it he goes you just
gotta watch out for the pumpkin [ __ ]
whole thing about pumpkin [ __ ] and it
was great fun I don't want to knock you
but I feel like look I went to one show
once was a Jimmy Buffett concert where
he was improvising in between songs and
he was talking about he used to be a
pumpkin [ __ ] you can maybe see a
pumpkin Jimmy
[Laughter]
remember I just want to make the locals
feel like I know who they are what
they're all about
he's such she's so good Jimmy yeah you
really here's yeah he does your your
Ellis handler in London did you do that
did you try to pick up on some things
about you know some stuff that I was
experiencing but not the general stupid
stuff like Jimmy Buffett just said you
know I just had a good time being in
London and it was just it was a delight
to perform there but in general I'm
really you know like I've got a hankerin
to go to Nashville so I'll make a call
and you know like I don't want to go
there and I go there but in general like
or Austin or you know there's certain
cities I like you know and yeah your
hometown I enjoyed I play was do the
Neptune er know what's the what's the
downtown town Musik nightclub place they
do stand up and a crocodile or that know
the tripled or tripled or I just did
that yeah isn't it amazing trip was
always fantastic great spot for you so I
did the triple door and I really enjoyed
that at some point I'll go back and do
the triple door but in general I like
sleeping in my own bed or napping as I
said I'm so busy filming that and I was
just in Chicago doing some stand-up I
was in New York doing some stand-up I
don't really want to I don't need to I
loved it it look if I'm getting it out
if I'm doing a couple hours awake here
do ya you know why do I need to work the
road because the road for me I'll do a
tour at some point and when I'm when I
finally decide to film my comedy special
I will in fact go on the road to prepare
for that and record new sets and try I'm
working with Matt Edgar he's all set
yeah that's awesome
he's great I talk about a guy man I
started to get at The Comedy Store right
talk about a guy like that it's just so
I mean we were doing those shitty open
mics and waiting for hours and getting
bumped at the Comedy Store after waiting
for hours
and then but but having that community
of guys that you kind of went through
that with you know to knock how shitty
that was but be supportive of each other
I can get the next night and he's grown
so much he's done he's doing great and
he but I have that with see here's the
difference I have that with famous
people I have that with John Stewart or
Conan Conan O'Brien show the other night
yeah we used to be roommates yeah Bob
Odenkirk who's filming better call Saul
I remember he and I sitting on the steps
of Second City both lamenting that no
one liked us or gave a [ __ ] about us
professionally you know and to go
through that together and then one day
being on the Sony lot and there's a big
better call Saul poster right next to a
big Goldberg's poster oh so you remember
everything those dark moments and you'll
have that with these people
and it had the lipo people like how do
you know someone so I go well we've
known each other since we were nothing
yeah if we never forget that right never
was a Colbert at the box office together
that's insane and they uttered phones
and took reservations to you and now
you're just on Colbert and then Colbert
well would you do [ __ ] when you work
together like it was it we talked about
it I think yeah that's so crazy you
could just walk out there like yet now
you're hosting a show I'm on these both
shows yes it's a very look at what I've
done in this but that suppose the thing
but that's the thing that I you know
it's really hard the journey is hard and
it's long and you just got to enjoy the
journey that's I'm saying you get to a
point where you like go oh I should
really enjoy the audition yeah it should
be stressful want it don't want it
should be no stress yeah because a it's
the worst possible scenario is I don't
get the big which is the same thing that
would happen if you stay at home or if
you do great and you're just not exactly
what they want so it's like you know
have enjoy enjoy it and I do that with
my stand-up all the time man I just have
joy and that's how I get by by
improvising a lot is to be so
appreciative of being able to do it
during the holiday season I think was
this past year when we were at the store
and you hooked up I think I brought you
up
Santa Ono couple years ago a couple
years ago okay but that was an
experiment I know but it was great
I didn't experiment I had just played
Santa wasn't on the Goldberg yes
everyone yet I said let me keep the
outfit and the beard and everything so I
went up with the Hat and the beard at
The Comedy Store then dressed below but
I was Santa as an [ __ ] I slammed
everyone slammed everything so
mean-spirited and it kind of worked and
it didn't but it was a fun experience
more work than didn't yeah but still
it's not something I would do again yeah
but see fun I'm taking advantage of I'm
gonna go up and do this what's the worst
that can happen the audience chance get
him out of here [ __ ] him right and hey
and now they just hate Santa no it's
like why not do that that's the worst is
that what you tell do you get people in
your family or outside your circle just
knowing so many people that are you can
you talk to my son or daughter they're
getting into the business like I hear
that from people yeah and I uh my only
advice is talk about what you care about
and be so good they can't say no meaning
you get to a point where you've just got
to be that great that you cannot be
denied yeah no Heather Pasternak open
for me a lot and I always tell her I go
up and suck go eat it you're still gonna
open for me what's the worst that can
happen you have an experience because
all your stand-up sets including mine
now
yeah our learning experiences yeah but
their learning experiences and you can
make them joyful just do it even with a
bad crowd I'll have fun I won't let them
ruin it you know and they're they're
people the way I know when I'm not funny
and if I'm not funny and the crowd is
great and that hurts me
yeah that stays with me on the drive
home but if I go up and I know I got it
and I'm feeling funny damn it I'm funny
and sometimes an audience can suck see
Seinfeld and I have disagreed on this
that he feels that it's always your
fault and I say no it's not there are
nights where I go up
and I'm really cooking I'm cooking
backstage I'm just cooking I got on the
groove and I know it and they just don't
groove to me whether it's their
education whether it's their DNA whether
it's the kind of day they had whether
it's the weather outside don't know
maybe you got they got the wrong weed
from Whoopi but yes
maybe they got the one but yeah
collectively there can be a group of
people sometimes they sure but yes they
all came up just but like I said if
they're great and you can feel it and
you just don't know all right yeah yeah
mm-hmm that feeling sucks how do you how
do you you know fix that well I tried of
a sense of humor about it when I'm
onstage yeah you know I make fun of
myself
but when I Drive home I'm like oh and
that takes that's the kind of set that
you need to go up onstage again and have
a good set to shake up he meters yeah I
last week was at Zanies in Chicago and I
usually when I play Zanies I stay out in
the suburbs I do out what's it called
Rosemont okay beautiful room and I grew
up learning at the Downtown room and I
happen to do two sets it was going there
for the Cubs opener which by the way was
snowed out yeah I came home so crazy so
I do two sets amber yes yeah yeah okay
so downtown is a very difficult room yes
but it's extra difficult if you
improvise and I had really good sets but
there wasn't a time that I was war it
wasn't working my ass off I come back
Friday night I had this past Friday I
have a set at the improv and I gotta say
did really good not great but really
good moments of greatness but in general
really good and I just felt like and
they were good on it's a bit like well
if that's just didn't feel right then
Saturday night this past there and I was
at flappers first show in boom second
show boom and then it made me feel
better because I was off in Chicago and
I was off the Friday at The Improv so I
needed to go on stage someplace where I
had the groove and I did and I felt
great and I'm coming off that now I'm
still feeling that it's almost it's sort
of the inning the Yankees just kind of
you just kind of get used to that
feeling but if you have those sets where
then it's not as good well you know the
truth is though I don't know if the
audience is in Chicago and especially at
the improv even knew that I wasn't
having my best doing my best work
because they didn't know the probably
not you know it's probably your head
yeah I know I know the nuance there you
guys know the nuances yeah of like yeah
they liked me but I wasn't so great
tonight
you know I was okay you know and then
the next thing you're like and they may
not even like you as much but you're
like oh I was grooving you know
absolutely it's always it's it's more
you know you know and people who
repeatedly see you I brought a friend
with me they to the Friday night show
and she was at the first Saturday show
and I told her and she's like what are
you talking about that was a great show
on Friday and then she saw the first
show Saturday she's like oh I completely
get what you're talking about cuz they
could feel it cuz she experienced both
but an audience one show they don't know
you know Jimmy Buffett you ever had some
shows in front of some bad crowds a
Mensa if we smoked weed with Jimmy
Buffett what would be the will be the
first thing we would do like what's your
go to strong identity would you go to
the farmers market here in town so when
you're in your home you have your own
what's the name of your gumbo Jeff
thanks for making time both you guys I
mean the best by the way it's an honor
to be on your show
thanks an honor to kind of look forward
to doing it again
and please ask me but we'll hey well I
respect both of you immensely
thank you both funny guys we're bringing
Jimmy - yeah by the way covert season
starts oh that I don't start filming
till August doesn't go on until
sometimes never come back
curb I don't know when it goes alright I
start filming April 25th but I don't
even know if if the Goldbergs have run
out this current season oh so on yeah no
no I'm saying in terms of new episodes
ok still might be coming out i but we're
at April yeah new episodes still oh yeah
yeah and then and then if you're in LA
go to the Hollywood improv on Friday
nights and you'll probably get laid with
Jeff Garlin yeah with Jeff Garlin I can
guarantee they won't get laid with me
I'll leave them alone when they're
getting laid
getting laid with me but I think they'll
probably get laid I do I really feel
that about my audience that's the
respect I show my audience I think
everyone in there well yeah you'll
probably get laid can't guarantee it
I don't call the show you will get yeah
I don't call the show you might get laid
I think it's probably gonna happen every
Friday please thanks Dan by the way
you're doing it soon
yeah what are you doing to it when any
Friday that I'm in town I will I will
get your number from Adam and then we'll
set that up yes because I'd love to do
it you doing my count restore show
tomorrow right I am yeah hold on take a
few steps back hello 17th are you gonna
do like I'll do it if I can do 3rd hold
on like oh yeah hold us here I just want
to make sure that if you're too busy no
no I'm a big bowl of golden yeah cuz I
found myself on a show I'm at The Improv
tomorrow night and I don't know how I
ended up on this particular show yeah
son so I'm on yours is yours opium
proverb no County store main remain what
terms of that starts at 8:30 there I and
we're gonna put you on later so you
could do more time great so can I go on
like with them nine thirty nine twenty
perfect yeah alright so I'll see you
there at nine twenty great and and oh
that you can check when you're going on
there tomorrow and then let me know and
we'll figure it out or is that supposed
to pay what's I mean yes when you're
going on it
no I'm saying okay oh yeah no one can
see me there DeMarcus is not coming out
till next week yeah but this is still
fun conversation so I'm glad you
reminded me great
yeah so I will be there I will be there
I do and a half hour bringing Jimmy
what's it know Jimmy were mapping with
me what are you doing tomorrow night
late night
[Music]
slow down
[Applause]
[Music]